[Music]
Game of Thrones Season eight has just
seen its full-length trailer released
and there's a lot to unpack from it
it appears that fans of the show are in
for a real treat and the trailer seems
outstanding from beginning to end
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the trailer as well as what
certain things signify there may be some
spoilers here so if you don't want to
know anything about the show then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
but without the way let's dive into my
breakdown of the Game of Thrones Season
8 trailer okay so the trailer opens with
Arya Stark
fearfully running from something before
stating that she knows death he has many
faces and questioning which one will
appear further next there's a real sense
of momentum to the trailer and
throughout it's clear that our
characters are gearing up for a great
battle against the undead awash with
dragons and large scale armies by its
midsection it confirms something that
many fans have been suspecting for a
while Jon will indeed be riding a dragon
whilst this is not shown the fact that
he is Targaryen and approaching one
whilst Daenerys approaches the other
seems to sell it for me John will of
course need this in the battle against
the night king which the trailer heavily
teases though he will have to discover
his true identity and that he adds yes
just slept with his aunty
yikes yikes yikes another massively
notable aspect is that Jaime Lannister
is indeed returning and fighting for the
north we see Jaime in the heat of battle
as another member of the same skirmish
that area is fighting in which could
potentially be against the night King in
addition to this we also get a look at
the golden company which is a mercenary
army that has been hired by Circe's to
fight for her they look like a very
formidable force and whilst no
confirmation has been made of their
leader it appears to be either Jaime or
a brand new character named Harry
Strickland who has been cast as the
golden company's leader
it's clear that the coalition is being
formed between the groups and it's
outstanding to see them all fighting
alongside one another this was teased at
in earlier clips and while Sansa will
obviously not be happy that John bent
the knee it's clear that she understands
why this had to happen
overall the trailer got me massively
pumped up for the season and I can't
wait for it to begin in April this would
by far the most excited that I've ever
been for a TV show and I can't wait to
see it all go down
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the trailer and what you took from it
leave them in the comments below and if
you enjoyed this video then please like
it and make sure you check out my
breakdown of everything we know so far
about season 8 which would be linked at
the end this is a channel for people who
will never miss in television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]